I am gonna try to link
all the books that I have read on my Amazon storefront,
the link in my bio.
But let's just get started.
All the, like,
crunchy mom books that I recommend.
How to heal your metabolism.
I read this right before I got pregnant,
and this is why I started my whole journey with,
like, foods and,
like, raw milk and all the stuff. Literally,
this looks at the foundation for me on the what to eat.
How to eat. This is amazing.
So 10 out of ten.
How does human your metabolism?
By Kate Dearie.
I read these two are pregnant. Um,
be your child's pediatrician and be your own doctor.
Um, both from the same.
I think it's from the same.
Yeah, the same author.
Um, and I still go back to these for, like,
home remedies
anytime I have something.
I go into this,
these two books,
whether for myself or for my daughter,
and it's amazing.
Also a lot of information on,
you know what pokes that I want to say
because I don't want to get censored, but, yeah,
real food for pregnancy.
I read this while I was pregnant.
I agree with a lot of things in this book,
but I don't agree with some things,
so I give it, like, a.
I got 8 out of 10.
How smart is your baby?
I also read this while pregnant.
Um, it's just, like,
really good for, like,
learning on Like,
baby development and, like,
swear Learned, like,
babies need to be on the floor a lot and,
like, not in,
like, you know,
swings and all this stuff.
So basically,
this book is for that.
The first 40 days.
A crucial book
full of, like,
things for postpartum,
for recipes,
um, foods that you should be eating.
Just, this book is amazing.
I, I, I wish I would have applied more of this stuff,
but next time around,
I'm definitely gonna be rereading this
and applying this,
because it just,
it makes sense.
Anime's guide to childbirth.
I get this, like,
at 11 out of 10
because so much information on,
like, childbirth.
If you're planning to, like,
do an unmedicated birth,
this is the book for you.
And it's also on faith based,
so I love that.
The Mama Natural Pregnancy and childbirth, um,
guide to pregnancy and childbirth book.
It was good,
but I wouldn't repurchase
because I don't agree with a lot of,
like, I mean,
I agree with some things,
but not a lot of, like,
the foods and stuff that she recommends.
Um, it's, like,
a little bit more traditional.
So, yeah, like
a 7 out of 10.
This book, Safe Infant Sleep.
I read this while pregnant,
and it's just basically, like,
all the information on co sleeping.
If you're, like,
you know, kind of on defense on it,
this book is really good for,
to make your decision.
And it just.
Nick Shows you,
you know, the safeways and all that stuff.
How to raise a healthy child in spite of your doctor.
Love, love, love this doctor. Robert mon.
I don't know how to say his last name, but he.
This book is amazing.
I actually read this right before I found that I
was pregnant, so I.
This book holds a lot of, like,
memories for me, but, again,
speaks a lot,
unlike pokes,
if you know what I'm talking about.
And, like, childhood stuff
and diseases and stuff and.
Really good book,
this one. The Womanly Art of breastfeeding.
You need to get it if you're planning on breastfeeding,
because I Learned most breastfeeding stuff in this book.
I'm 19 months into my journey,
and I still go back to this book,
like, for weaning and stuff.
I've been going back to this book,
so I really recommend this book. Like,
this is like my.
Your guide. Like,
you need to be reading this book.
Like, I read it while I was pregnant,
and then postpartum,
I reread it.
I still go back to it.
Like, it's gold.
And this one,
functional maternity.
Actually just finished reading this one.
I wish I would have read this
before I got pregnant with my daughter,
but that's okay.
Um, and this is just all the information on, like,
things that you need to be doing,
preconception,
the foods that you need to be eating,
how to prevent, like,
things that happen.
During labor.
Like it. It 10 out of 10.
Recommend this book
if you can read it
either while you're pregnant
or before you get pregnant.
I really recommend.
So I'm gonna link.
Try to link all these in my Amazon storefront, but yeah.